[Music]
so that on saturdays i do arms now
people say to take sunday off as a
recovery day but then again most people
don't look like this
what about you governor preppie you uh
getting to the gym much these days or
what not really you know because my
schedule's just so packed
just too bad the governor doesn't get
summers off
uh so you must be pretty busy too kelly
what's going on with your new company
well it's more of a wellness brand
um our mission is to encourage
positivity through manifestation and
actualized optimism oh that's so cool
so what is the company well it's more of
a wellness brand it's called
dr happy wait
who's the doctor
me
i'm a doctor of optimism but you can't
call yourself doctor i mean i'm a doctor
but i got my phd in educational
psychology well actually a doctor is
just a label like uh all natural oh did
i mention that we're actually selling an
all-natural rejuvenation supplement yeah
it's doctor recommended by me
except doctor is not just a label it's a
title that you earn through
years and years of hard work
now this is what i like to see the old
gang back together again
don't forget the alumni photo's at 10.
it's at 10
so don't forget we'll be there ron don't
worry
have you guys met before of course
governor morris so good to see you again
ron todman
it's been a while you look great
thank you mr toadman uh if you'll excuse
me uh
i have to take a call ah
hi
i know that sounded like a lame excuse
but
i also have to take a call
did you hear that dig about teachers
having summers off
he's got a lot of nerve i'm working
every day of the summer monday abs
tuesday arms wednesday i mean i love
kelly but that business
i don't think even she knows what that
is screech is so lucky he and kevin get
to live on the international space
station so it doesn't have to deal with
all this i hate to say it but zach and
kelly have changed they're so
self-absorbed now
you know i guess that's what happens
when you move to sacramento you go
hollywood it makes me sad i just want it
to be like old times unfortunately you
can't unless you have a time machine
slater that's it you're a genius
i'm really not i've been taking this
ukrainian protein powder that i just
found out and smalling's your brain our
class time capsule let's dig it up and
then the four of us can go through it
together and maybe it'll give us a
chance to remember why we were friends
in the first place are we sure we
shouldn't just swipe some beers and hang
out in my office instead i just got the
lakers version of monopoly
i'll go get my shovel
oh my god look
somebody's already here come on let's go
i want to get the time capsule but it's
not worth our lives
oh it's just zach and kelly stop hiding
behind me oh hey what are you guys doing
here
i think the same thing you are trying to
go back to the time when we were all
best friends
[Music]
you saved my life that night i will be
celebrating 30 years caffeine free this
april i would love for you all to be
there oh we wouldn't miss it
oh my gosh you guys remember no
you guys put on swan lake because that
was the only way i could graduate
wait why was it the only way i could
graduate can you remember this you guys
helped my grandfather save his hawaiian
hotel oh
you guys let's go to hawaii this year
together i love that song
oh i didn't even see this you guys
oh little note
for slater love your best friend preppy
you're always doing stuff like this man
surprising me with little gifts you knew
i'd adore was i because that doesn't
really seem like something i would do
oh that seems like something i would do
you